notamment franco allemand ensuite les
modalités sont soit rapide et je veux
juste revenir sur un point sur la
question du déni public des 3%
en effet actuellement on est à peu près
dans les clous il ya des propositions
lardons convoi à l'arrivée en direct et
bien d' emmanuel macron qui est
accueilli par la chancelière angela
merkel vous le voyez sur ces images en
direct une longue poignée de main
appuyée on parlait d'un accueil
chaleureux
elle l'avait déjà fait le 16 mars
dernier elle avait accepté de le
rencontrer et on se souvient
effectivement qu'elle avait pris non pas
position ont explicitement pour emmanuel
macron sachant que son camp c'est que tu
es quand même françois fillon
mais elle a toujours eu une forme de
bienveillance un vis-à-vis des manuels
macro on sait qu'il est merkel
compatible que effectivement sa
dimension européenne et cette vision
qu'il a de l'europe et la manière dont
il a placé au centre de son programme a
toujours été plutôt très bien vu et à
bruxelles et à berlin
et sachant qu effectivement ce moteur
franco-allemand qu'on dit en panne
depuis la fin 2000 terran coll
avaient effectivement besoin d'un
nouveau souffle donc le fait de voir
aujourd'hui respecté cette tradition
républicaine que de faire ce premier
rendez-vous à l'étranger avec angela
merkel qui est donc la doyenne des chefs
d'état dans l'union européenne elle
brigue ici son quatrième mandat angela
merkel plus de 4000 jours au pouvoir
face donc aux plus jeunes chefs d'état
en exercice désormais dans l'union
européenne
c'est aussi assez intéressant à voir ce
choc de générations comment est ce
qu'ils vont pouvoir
si toutefois elle est réélue en
septembre prochain fonctionner ensemble
et faire en sorte de relancer un petit
peu la machine marc olivier panis est
important aussi les relations
interpersonnelles entre les nouveaux
chefs d'état oui c'est nouveau et eon
gagnait merkel on voit qu'ils parlent
assez facilement et directement il ya
une conversation qui s'engagent je pense
que la langue des changes et l'anglais
c'est vrai que le fait qu emmanuel
macron tu sois à l'aise en anglais ça
doit faciliter quand même manière qu'il
a fait une intervention là une bonne
université de berlin dès janvier en
anglais sont des loyers pro-européen de
discours complet oui il ya de bonnes
relations personnelles on disait thomas
semble que entre la chancelière et
emmanuel macron situe plutôt dans
l'avion qui emmenait françois hollande
à berlin il ya cinq ans jour pour jour
il y avait déjà dit mme abena seront
donc les deux se connaissent depuis très
très longtemps et je crois qu'ils
parlent ils partent pas de zéro
sont vus plusieurs fois entre temps
macron a beaucoup travaillé avec sigmar
gabriel
il a essayé aussi travaillé avec hervé
votre cash robe lavande de s'approcher
de gabriel ça n'a pas tellement bien
fonctionné alors l'a choisi mais bon qui
finissent de l'économie est un canal
voulait peut-être commenter les images
me fera toujours ses devoirs macron il
est complètement à nous on dirait que
c'est la dixième fois qu'il fait tout ça
comme le jour de la passation des
pouvoirs donc
et oui on avait l'impression que c'est
pas la première fois qu il ya vraiment
très à l'aise et c'est ça qui est
tellement impressionnante tout est tombé
après nous rien ils ne parlent pas le
monde hip hop il parle mais comme vous
avez dit il parle parfaitement anglais
et merkel
je crois qu'elle parle assez bien on
entend les applaudissements il ya quand
même un petit engouement peut-être
commandait la venue d'emmanuel maquereau
en allemagne elvire fabry et je pense
que l'on peut ajouter qu edouard
philippe lui même avait passé son bac en
allemagne et germanophone enfin voila on
voit que l'équipe entre filles et yen
son conseiller d'affaires affaires
étrangères et conseiller diplomatique on
a également c'est une équipe
vous parliez goulard tout à l'heure les
récents mouvements ministrable c'est une
équipe germanophile est en train de se
constituer autour de monaco ou encore il
fane aura beaucoup de signes a renvoyé à
la chancelière allemande
effectivement et moi je me souviens on
avait couvert à public sénat il ya
quelques mois
le
conseil des ministres franco allemand
qui a donc qui se tient chaque année et
cette année ils s'étaient tenus de
mémoire à amiens d'ailleurs terre terre
de manuel macron et il était donc avec
sigmar gabriel et il avait pour habitude
régulièrement de faire des conférences
de presse
ensemble et c'était très très très très
intéressant de voir à quel point il
était extrêmement à l'aise en fait dans
ce dans ce système très international
très européen et à quel point on fait le
franco-allemand était quelque chose pour
lui d' extrêmement naturelle finalement
je pense donc voilà on entend la marque
ça irait en tire donc cette image est
assez forte
de voir emmanuel macron avec angela
merkel donc avec une différence d'âge et
peut-être une différence de pratique du
pouvoir enlever mais voilà donc ce
conseil des ministres à l'époque avait
avait été assez intéressant à suivre là
dessus pour voir comment cet homme qui
était finalement le plus jeune du
gouvernement
fonctionner assez bien en fait avec la
plupart de ses homologues
est ce donc en anglais et avec tout le
monde ce qui n'était pas le cas de tous
un effectivement dans le gouvernement
français marc olivier panis on peut
ajouter sur la densité des relations
franco-allemandes que quand emmanuel
macron et ministre de l'économie il
avait commandé un rapport donc avec
sigmar gabriel son homologue allemand à
deux économistes jean pisani ferry et
eric albert line et jean pisani-ferry
donc qui dirigeait à l'époque francs
stratégie est devenu ensuite le
responsable du programme global des
manuels macron et donc avec eric end
airlines il avait proposé tout un
ensemble de plans de relance européens à
partir de la stratégie franco allemand
donc il ya tout un ensemble de
réflexions qui sont déjà utilisable qui
sont déjà sur la table et que mm macro
connaît très bien les éléments qui
manquent mais on en a parlé un peu de
chocs de l'âge c'est ça mais il ya aussi
un choc de culture administrative parce
que en france vous un an dans le système
des cabinets ministériels vous avez des
jeunes qui sont souvent brillant qui a
beaucoup l'idée beaucoup de volonté de
faire changer les choses
en allemagne on à l'administration qui
change pas tellement vous avez parfois
des gens qui sont là depuis 20 ans qui
pense qu'ils ont tout vu tout lu tout
lui est
il n'y a rien de nouveau sous le soleil
ces deux cultures qui s'entraînent
expliqué c'est pour ça que c'est une
bonne chose que l'épée tienne est là
parce qu'il me connaît très bien la
russie dans le monde et il sait comment
il faut s'y prendre pour ne pas être
repoussé tout de suite par fabrice macro
séguéla merkel il va y en avoir il va y
en avoir parce qu'on l'a évoquée par
petits bouts il ya un certain nombre de
sujets sur lequel il faut s'accorder et
des sujets qui ne sont pas nouveaux sur
le rôle social par exemple il peut avoir
des points d'achoppement sur l'europe
sociale l'europe sociale ce qui peut
être fait d'abord au sein de la zone
euro et plus largement
ça dépend justement de la mise en place
de ce budget européen qui pourrait être
conditionnée à au respect d'un certain
nombre de droits sociaux qui sont
aujourd'hui ce que cherche à porter la
commission européenne mais qui ne sont
molles qui ne sont pas contraignants
donc là il pourrait y avoir des éléments
intéressants mais si ça ne se limite à
la zone euro ça ne résout pas à pas le
problème des écarts de réglementation
qui a entre certains noms de pays de
l'est notamment ceux qui sont évoqués
pour la la directive des travailleurs
détachés donc ça ne résoudrait pas tous
les problèmes mais il faut tenir compte
aussi 2
du fait qu'il ya cette attente qui
pèsent aujourd'hui sur la france et sur
ce renouveau du couple franco allemand
est très forte
on le voit chez nos voisins en espagne
yaya et vous parlez de lune de miel
il va falloir être prudent en effet il
ya toute une série d'enjeux sur lesquels
on espère pouvoir avancer mais ça va
prendre du temps et ça ne se résoudra
pas en quelques mois et on se souvient
un petit peu au moment de l'élection de
de françois hollande en 2012
on s'était demandé bâti la chercher a
dit le nouveau show d'air la désillusion
est venue assez rapidement
là on espère que ça s'engage c'est
intéressant ça dès le 9 avril le nouveau
sol alors le nouveau manuel macro est
exactement mais en fait là c'est
toujours très drôle à chaque fois qu'il
y a quelqu'un plutôt sur la fibre
sociale sont le présente comme le
nouveau showrunner
mais en italie on le présente aussi
comme le nouveau renzi et et c'est ça
qui est assez drôle c'est que la manière
dont la grille de lecture qui est fait
depuis l'étranger des manuels macron
c'est un peu comme son micro ni droite
ni gauche c'est un peu comme le en même
temps c'est à dire que tout le monde en
fan va un peu pouvoir projeter les
aspirations qu'on a et les attentes
qu'on peut avoir de la france comme
moteur potentiel de l'europe
après las qui va se jouer c'est
effectivement sa capacité en france à
réformer et derrière donc cet alignement
de planètes et les négociations
possibles qui vont pouvoir se faire pour
approfondir la zone euro et plus
largement parce que c'est ça aussi qui
va se jouer
comment réconcilier les français et les
européens avec l'union européenne